attendez regardez ce que j'ai trouvé qu
as-tu trouvé cette fois l'espagne je ne
veux pas me marier
[Musique]
le roi tu intime l'ordre de devenir les
pousses de frédéric
celui qui réussira à retrouver la
princesse l'épousera héritera du royaume
avec éloi est prêt à la donner en
mariage au premier qui les a princess va
se marier avec moi vous devez retrouver
la princesse
[Musique]
il faut absolument que je l'a sauvé
à bord donne c'est trop dangereux le roi
de la montagne et la honte est la
prophétie ce donc le groupe il faut
toujours croire ou les gens
[Musique]
le roi de la montagne
vous allez me dire ou es des noms
[Applaudissements]
princesse n'en a rien à faire pour toi
tu crois vraiment qu'elle va t'épouser
m